درجه الحراره خارج الطائره الى 32 درجه
مئويه
من اجل السلام
حتى صرفت طائره تماما وتصبح اشاره ربط
الحزام وتفتح الابواب الرئيسيه ويسمح لكم
السلامه بالمغادره
مذكرين حضراتكم الكرام بناخذ حقائبكم
وجميع متعلقاتكم الشخصيه قبل مغادره
الظاهره
مره اخرى نعبه عن اسره شركه بدر للطيران
قاسم محمد احمد ومساعده محمد ابراهيم
الطيران املين من الله ايضا رافعين
والتضرع والتوتر بان يعود لسوداننا الحبيب
امنه واستقراره وعافيته وان يحفظوا الشباب
والبلاد والعباد وان يحفظنا بما
السودانيين والنعمه السلام
بكره احلى بكره يا خرطوم تغني يرجع الناس
في رحابه
ودلاله
وفكره
يا جماله ويبقى في المغرى سمرنا وتوت صف
خسرت اتمنى لكم طيب الاقامه في مدينه
بورسودان او اينما كانتكم رافقتكم السلام